panicked tourists watch has a wall of
volcanic ash threatens to envelop them
[Music]
minutes earlier they stood on the
volcano's edge
now they bore witness to its might 47
people were on [ __ ] re Island at the
time of the eruption some managed a
narrow escape craziest thing to ever
happen in our lifes just happened we
were touring the volcano for about an
hour but just ten minutes after we left
and got on the boat the volcano started
erupting the boat turned around went
back to the island to try to help the
people who are still there I'm not sure
if everyone got out alive a number of
those on the island were too close to
the eruption emergency crews airlifted
the injured some in a critical condition
this cruise ship couldn't leave on
schedule a group of its passengers were
on the island New Zealand's Prime
Minister Jacinda Arden spoke of her
grief at the loss of life she said the
main focus was now on recovery and
returning loved ones to their families
our durn also confirmed she had been in
touch with her Australian counterpart
scientists had noted an uptick in
volcanic activity on the island in
recent weeks now questions are being
asked as to why people were allowed so
close to a disaster waiting to happen
well joining us now from Auckland New
Zealand is journalist Carissa parameter
Carissa police have now lost an
investigation into the deaths at the
volcano what exactly are they looking
into actually earlier they backtracked
police have stepped back from their
position saying that a communal a
criminal investigation has been launched
into the circumstances behind the [ __ ]
re the white island eruption in a press
statement police set to correct an
earlier statement it is too early to
confirm whether there will also be a
criminal investigation police confirmed
that they were investigating the death
of India
visuals on fake ID on behalf of the
coroner in parallel with WorkSafe New
Zealand investigation so WorkSafe New
Zealand is the workplace health and
safety regulator and administrator here
and they will be investigating and
considering all of their relevant work
health and safety issues surrounding
this tragic event although it wasn't
mentioned who will be charged or
investigation investigated in this case
Terry what more is now about the people
who are still missing police earlier
also mentioned that the surveillance
photos of the island showed what is
believed to be six bodies which were
covered in ash based on the effects of
the eruption on the bodies they
mentioned the recovery operation will
need to be handled with expert skill and
care it was confirmed that there were 47
people in total on [ __ ] when the
eruption happened 38 of them were from
the crews ovation of the Seas two are
from the UK or from Germany 24 from
Australia and others from New Zealand
China Malaysia and United States
currently 31 victims are in the hospital
and all burn units across the country
currently are in full capacity how is
the government in New Zealand responding
to this because we've been hearing quite
a bit from the Prime Minister yeah Prime
Minister Jacinda Arden told Parliament
that there are questions which must be
asked about the eruption and those
questions must be answered she revealed
that police and WorkSafe would be
issuing statements that the police
backtracked earlier but yeah Arthur and
also made comments during her official
statement to Parliament that there was
no limit to New Zealand's capacity to
embrace those impacted by this tragedy
Krista thank you very much for bringing
us up-to-date there that was journalist
Carissa parameter in Auckland New
Zealand